that in very short order in the
lifetimes of people in this room humans
have gotten very very big all of a
sudden extremely big able to cast a very
long shadow and we've gotten big too
fast before we could figure out what the
consequences of that we're going to be
the best proof of it in real time is the
ongoing climate saga now unfolding I
wrote the first book for a general
audience about global warming 20 years
ago the time it was still a hypothesis I
thought a very strong one the science
was very clear okay the molecular
structure of co2 we know enough about to
know that it traps heat they would
otherwise radiate back out to space
since we were burning enough coal and
gas and oil to put lots of co2 into the
atmosphere it seemed in many ways quite
clear what the outcome would be but it
also seemed emotionally counterintuitive
how could we have gotten large enough to
be affecting everything that happened on
the surface of the earth because that's
what we're talking about every process
that we see in the last couple of years
18 months that hypothesis that turned to
consensus has actually turned again to a
kind of panic um as we begin to
understand that these changes are
happening on a larger scale and much
more quickly than we had anticipated but
what's scary really about it is that at
a certain point we're not directly doing
it we create the conditions by burning
coal and gas and oil and putting carbon
in the atmosphere to set off these chain
of reactions but past a certain point
we're not in control of it anymore so
that even if we did everything right and
stopped burning that coal and gas and
oil very quickly it's by now an open
question as to how long that melt will
continue and what that you know whether
or not we'll be able to rein this system
back in we have a number finally to
express this and this is this most
important number in the world that I've
been describing um it came from
our foremost climatologists NASA team in
in January of 2008 led by Jim Hansen
they published a paper in which they
said that 350 parts per million co2 was
the most that we could have in the
atmosphere for any long period of time
if we wish to retain as they put it in
the abstract of a peer-reviewed
scientific paper if we wish to maintain
a planet similar to the one on which
civilization developed into which life
on Earth is adapted the trouble is it's
one hell of a tough number okay we're
already past it we're at 387 parts per
million and rising two parts per million
per annum at the moment we're like we're
not like the guy who goes to the doctor
and the doctor says off you know if you
keep up this cheese eating habit of
yours someday your cholesterol will be
too high you know um we're like the guy
who goes the doctor and doctor says look
we're going to have a talk right now
your cholesterol is too high and if it
stays in this zone as long as it's in
this zone your chance of having a heart
attack or a stroke is really good and
you better hope you can get it down
before that heart attack or stroke
happens well that's where we are as a
planet and those heart attacks and
strokes are starting to happen that's
why the Arctic is melting and so about a
year ago we formed this thing called
350.org okay knowing that in December of
this year in Copenhagen the world's
leaders will meet and come up with the
next big treaty on carbon we used to
think it would be an evolutionary
document that would expand the Kyoto
Accord some and include mark now we know
it has to be given the science a really
transformative agreement it has to not
just be some agreement they'll agree on
something you know you know did 880
heads of state in one place and say we
failed you know delegate what we need is
an agreement that actually gets us
towards stability that takes that number
seriously October 24th is the day we've
picked for a day of global action
on 350 okay because it's about six weeks
before Copenhagen and we need to take
that most important number and make it
the most visible number in the world and
they're going to be thousands of actions
that day we sent out the first letter
about this two days ago out around the
web and we've already got I've two
hundred and some registered actions in
25 countries we that'll grow
exponentially as the week's go on if you
guys help they're going to be people
high up in the Himalayas with banners
there's going to be 350 scuba divers in
the Great Barrier Reef we just found out
that they're going to be a research team
on Easter Island and they're going to
string banners from the noses of those
stone gentlemen you know on and on and
on everything I need from you guys two
things one to organize some of those
sort of things where you are okay here
in New Haven or wherever you're from or
through whatever groups and communities
you belong to has absolutely no
guarantee that this strategy will work
in fact there's absolutely no guarantee
any strategy will work it is possible
that we have waited too long to get
started there are scientists who say the
physical momentum of these systems is
great enough that it's too late to
meaningfully arrest them and we're going
to see the best science indicates that
there is still a window of opportunity
albeit a narrow one albeit closing all
right rajendra pachauri the indian-born
head of the Intergovernmental Panel on
Climate Change who accepted the Nobel
alongside Gore said recently as far as
he could tell from reading the data that
they're getting that if we haven't made
fundamental changes in at least begun to
make very fundamental changes in our
energy system by 2012 okay the momentum
of these things will be too great 20
mean kids who entered Yale College in
last fall are going to be still in
school in 2012 okay wait doesn't do any
good to wait until you get out of
college to do something about this you
know it doesn't do any good to wait at
all that's the
thing that makes it different from any
kind of movement that we've had to build
before the arc of the physical universe
is short and it bends toward heat and if
we do not very quickly figure out how to
get this under control then we won't it
comes with a time limit that's the bad
news the good news is that all over the
world people are beginning to figure
that out and beginning to step up and
much of its coming from young people but
it can't come from young people alone it
needs to come from every kind of people
and you have it within you to help
enormously in that process and I hope
very very much that you will and I thank
you in advance for it thank